monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le drame
que viennent de subir les populations de
douma et la crise internationale que
nous vivons sont d'une telle intensité
qu'il était nécessaire et urgent
d'entendre la voix du parlement et je
souhaite remercier nombre de nos
collègues qui malgré le calendrier
constitutionnel et 3 sont présents ce
soir l'utilisation des armes chimiques
sur les populations civiles ne peut en
effet restés impunis
nos armées ont certes brillamment réussi
ses frappes mais rien n'est réglé en
syrie le roc de la défense ne sort pas
pour sa part indemne de cette opération
voilà quelques points que je souhaite
développer au nom de notre commission
devant vous ce soir
fallait-il intervenir cette question
cruciale c'est celle des preuves
est-ce bien le régime de bachar el assad
qui a commis ces atrocités
certes nous savons depuis à l'épée khan
shehoun que ce monstrueux personnage n'a
jamais hésité à utiliser des armes
chimiques contre son peuple
violant ainsi tous ses engagements
internationaux
nous savons aussi que dans cet orient
compliqué
toutes les manipulations sont possibles
les ennemis du matin pouvant devenir les
adversaires du soir
ce qui importe donc monsieur le ministre
c'est de savoir que ce sont nos propres
services de renseignement et nos experts
qui atteste de ses preuves vous avez
hier devant nous et encore tout à
l'heure confirmées solennellement devant
la représentation nationale
votre certitude sur l'origine de ces
massacres et sur l'origine de leurs
auteurs et donc si tel est le cas il
convenait de réagir réagir d'abord pour
porter un coup d'arrêt à ces pratiques
ignobles et rappeler qu'on ne peut gaz
et sa population pour mater une
rébellion
si nos sources sont exacts il est
vraisemblable que les objectifs détruit
il y a quatre jours étaient les mêmes
que ceux identifie en août 2013
sauf que cinq ans ont été perdus et que
des milliers d'innocents auront payé le
prix de notre indécision d'alors
et en cinq ans le visage des rebelles a
évolué hélas vers l'islamisme radical
alors quand on parle de lignes rouges
mieux vaut sanctionné et vite sinon ce
sont des sabres de bois il fallait le
faire aussi pour envoyer un message
clair aux alliés de la syrie et
particulièrement à la russie ce grand
pays avec lequel tant de liens nous
unissent doit aussi comprendre que le
rôle de grande puissance est
incompatible avec le non respect du
droit international
nous l'avons du res te rappeler à nos
collègues russes dans le dialogue serein
mais sans concession que nous avons eues
la semaine passée avec les représentants
du conseil de la fédération de russie
les frappes étaient elles fondées en
droit international
le respect du droit international
s'applique bien sûr d'abord à nous or
cette idéalement sur la base d'une
résolution votée par le conseil de
sécurité sous le régime du chapitre 7 de
la charte des nations unies autorisant
le recours à la force que ce genre
d'opération militaire trouve sa
légitimité incontestable mais force est
de constater que l'utilisation par la
russie à deux reprises dont six fois sur
le chimique à 12 reprises de son veto
sur le dossier syrien a paralysé
l'action du conseil de sécurité y
compris pour le volet humanitaire
là encore nous pouvons regretter que les
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité n'est pas tous accepté la
proposition française de s'abstenir
d'utiliser ce droit de veto en cas de
crimes de masse
le gouvernement s'appuie sur le
fondement de la résolution 21-18 de
septembre 2013 sur le démantèlement du
programme chimiques dont le paragraphe
21 que vous avez rappelé mentionne la
possibilité du recours à la force
bien sûr il aurait fallu en toute
rigueur une résolution ultérieure
mais face au blocage sciemment organisée
du conseil de sécurité
c'était la seule solution pour agir
nous le déplorons et nous souhaitons
qu'à l'avenir il le faudra bien
les nations unies trouve le moyen de
rompre la paralysie engendrée par
certains membres du conseil de sécurité
nos armées ont elles bien réaliser la
mission que leur a confiée le président
de la république oui certainement
dans ce contexte très tendu où toute
erreur d'exécution pouvait ouvrir la
voie à une escalade d'une gravité
exceptionnelle
nos forces armées ont réalisé un sans
faute que nous devons saluer en moins
d'une heure tous les objectifs fixés ont
été atteints et détruit sans aucune
perte de vie humaine additionnant les
heures de transit et la tension est
extrême de l'action
nos forces aériennes et navales ont
démontré une fois de plus leur parfaite
maîtrise et leur capacité de projection
à des milliers de kilomètres
appuyé par des services de renseignement
qui avait parfaitement préparé cette
opération les profs les procédures de
déconstruction entendez le téléphone
rouge ont parfaitement fonctionné
évitant tout contact avec les forces
aériennes russes dont près de 20 avions
étaient tous en vol d'observation dans
ce secteur à la même heure
je souhaite ici rendre au nom de notre
commission
un hommage solennel au travail de nos
militaires de ces femmes et de ces
hommes qui par leur dévouement par leur
courage et par leurs compétences
permettent à la france d'avoir l'une des
meilleures armées du monde
[Applaudissements]
le sénat le sénat j'en suis sûr aura à
coeur lors de l'examen de la prochaine
loi de programmation militaire de leur
assurer les conditions de vie
d'entraînement et d'équipement dont ils
ont besoin pour accomplir leur exigeante
mission cette action militaire
ouvre-t-elle une solution politique en
syrie
évidemment non et si un coup décisif a
été portée à la fabrication et au
stockage d'armes chimiques en syrie rien
n'indique qu'elles ont été détruites à
100%
bien au contraire on peut même imaginer
que nombre d'entre elles auront profité
de cette étrange semaine de tweets pour
être transférés dans d'autres sites
nous le savons bien aucune solution
militaire ne viendra à bout de ce
conflit
notre ennemi vous l'avez rappelé ce
n'est pas al asiri cedej et tous les
groupes liés à l'islamisme radical leur
éradication doit donc être achevés à
tout prix malheureusement cet objectif
se mêlent à des confrontations complexe
interne à cette région du monde dont
certaines durent depuis des décennies
conflit israélo-palestinien
confrontation sunnites chiites entre
l'arabie saoudite et l'iran
revendications kurdes inlassablement
réprimée par les turcs qui utilisent
maintenant la force contre des alliés
courageux face à des persécutions des
chrétiens d'orient
tout concourt à des explosions en chaîne
qui menace le monde d'instabilité et de
terrorisme
alors monsieur le ministre il vous reste
à repartir au combat mais celui là c'est
le combat de la paix
nous avons bien sûr souvent le sentiment
de l'impuissance mais nous avons aussi
la chance de pouvoir dialoguer avec le
monde entier et le sénat il prend
résolument sa part notre commission va
du reste assuré un suivi actif et
vigilant de cette crise il faut en effet
maintenir le dialogue avec la russie
bien sûr nous le faisons avec l'iran
avec la turquie
ce n'est pas si facile
ce sont les acteurs présents sur le
terrain mais aussi bien au-delà avec les
organisations africaines avec les
partenaires régionaux
l'arabie saoudite avec israël certes les
difficultés sont grandes et une fois de
plus le report a montré son impuissance
et ses divisions
la grande-bretagne assurer ses
responsabilités mais nos grands voisins
notamment nos amis allemands nous auront
laissé bien seul
sans même contribuer symboliquement à
cette opération
nous connaissons bien sûr les règles
d'engagement de leurs forces armées bien
différentes des nôtres mais un soutien
plus appuyé une déclaration nous aurait
sans doute rassurer et nous aurait posé
moins d'interrogations sur nos
perspectives de coopération en matière
de défense avec les britanniques aux
forces armées efficace il sera important
pour nous malgré le break site de
préserver une coopération de défense
étroite qui pourra prendre la forme d'un
traité spécifique avec l'union
européenne la commission des affaires
européennes
présidée par mon collègue jean visait
ainsi que notre commission seront très
mobilisés sur ce point alors monsieur le
ministre nous allons suivre et appuyez
vos efforts pour une diplomatie de la
paix ou une diplomatie du dialogue
le projet de résolution que la france a
fait circuler samedi est une première
étape
elle montre les efforts inlassables de
notre diplomatie pour remettre les
nations unies au centre du jeu
diplomatique et appelé les autres
nations à assumer leurs responsabilités
la visite en russie en mai du président
macron qui semble être confirmée est
très important elle devra lui permettre
de faire comprendre aux russes qu'ils ne
retrouveront leur rôle sur la scène
internationale que s'il respecte le
droit international
cette visite devra servir à la paie mais
il est un rôle particulier monsieur le
ministre que la france doit assumer
c'est la dimension humanitaire de ce
drame
derrière ce choc des grandes puissances
qui se mesure à l'aune de ces violences
il y à des hommes il y à des femmes il
ya des enfants qui ne demandaient qu'à
vivre en paix qui ne comprennent rien à
des enjeux qui les dépasse et sont
devenus au fil des sept années de guerre
les victimes des pires atrocités alors
monsieur le ministre
travailler pour que la sueur ou la syrie
retrouve la concorde civile travailler
pour que la syrie soit libéré de
l'islamisme radical pour une syrie où
chaque communauté
même minoritaires et sa place pour une
série où les exilés reviennent le vrai
pour les couloirs humanitaires
le vrai pour des zones de protection
pour ces malheureux qui ont déjà tout
perdu et fait en sorte que ces zones les
protège de ces armes inhumaines
peut-être même sûrement ne rêvons pas
gain de cause auprès des états meizu
mais vous aurez fait parler la voix de
la france auprès de ses victimes qui
méritent qu'on les sauve de l'enfer et
de la barbarie des hommes
merci monsieur le président